so as surreal as it is we're talking
about you
um flying around the Moon let's rewind
and talk about the origin story what's
the origin story of everyday astronaut
I used to be a professional photographer
so from 2008 until the end of 2016 that
was my income was photography full time
like you were an Instagram model into
butt pictures of yourself Instagram by
fitness model fitness model obviously uh
now the uh I I did I did a lot of
weddings I shot 150 weddings
um all around the world just subjects
all kinds of material like uh like uh
portrait also a lot of portrait work and
then just you know random like
commercial things like you know food and
beverages for businesses or like you
know uh
wheelchair ramp company I shot their
products like you know it's random
whatever a professional photographer
does in Cedar Falls Iowa you know when
did you uh fall in love with photography
with a visual medium do you remember
yeah I do actually remember I so I I
drew up uh I grew up drawing constantly
I I was the weird kid that might I would
bring a sketch pad to the restaurants
like every restaurant when I was growing
up until I was like 18 19 I literally
would just sit there and draw or waiting
for food and my parents like fostered
that date
when you know and I I'd be the weird kid
but I'd be engaging and talking but I'd
be sitting there drawing and I I was
always obsessed with realism and like
recreating and you know visualizing
things
and so when I got my hands on the
cameras actually my dad's old Pentax
that I first shot a on a film camera and
developing the film I didn't personally
develop but like you know getting the
film back back in those days
um you know I just was like so excited
about the idea that I had this visual
thing that I saw with my own eyes and
now I can stop time and capture it and
and show it to other people just kind of
like to me that was like the ultimate
form of of realism was like literally
showing you the photons basically that
affected this film
um and so I I mean I was I was 19 when I
got my first digital SLR a Canon 20D
and started shooting
um
and yeah I just I fell in love with it
it became like I got a job at a camera
store and you know basically all my
extra money went into buying everything
that I could at the time and I only
worked there for about exactly a year
before I went into pursuing photography
full time and
I basically was shooting weddings that I
could travel and pay like you know
afford to be able to
uh do some big trips every year and and
develop some kind of you know portfolio
of traveling and
not necessarily like not for you know I
guess Instagram wasn't much of a thing
at the time it's really just I liked
making big prints and having them
displayed and
that kind of stuff and pretty are you
still a Canon guy you still a Canon
elitist no no I I moved around I I did
Sony for a bit I still kind of shoot
mostly Canon glass but adapted to either
Sony lenses sorry like Canon lenses look
at you
what do you think about the um these
things that I'm using Sony a74 great
this is great see yeah it's uh I've uh
I've been you know I Googled around just
trying to find a camera that can do
video and photography pretty well and
obviously going was just like generic
lenses Prime I've resisted everything my
whole journey with these camera thing
I'm trying to figure stuff out is like
prime lenses seems so stupid so the
problem is it's like a fixed Zoom thing
yep it's like why
because I remember I was going to like
Ukraine
and thinking it's similar like uh
um yeah very similar to space flight but
you're very constrained because you're
going into an unknown environment you're
going to a war zone you're going to a
front you don't know what like you don't
know anything right and there's like a
little suitcase you have to like see
figure out like how do you film this
what's what's robust
um what gives you like a good image
versus a flexibility versus the weight
his weight is important there you have
to think about like can you really bring
like a bunch of zoom lenses and all that
kind of stuff so I had to learn really
quickly but yeah I've um
it's a whole journey that you've already
been on but it's nice to have a beginner
like me like to explore that I think
there is a
there's a nice thing just because we've
been talking about with The Beginner's
mind
to um
not let equipment
get in the way of like what your vision
is of what a thing should look like yeah
sometimes like especially if you're a
professional videographer a photographer
cinematographer whatever you call it you
can like fetishize equipment too much
you can get so much equipment and I've
interacted that because I've been trying
to learn from other people that have so
much more experience than me
I think their advice is often like
uh very pushing a lot of equipment
versus like
the final thing like how do you create
the art of it and like because to me
even photography is just like
storytelling and so like a lot of the
discussion to me
that I enjoy especially talking to
creative people is like the the final
story like how and I've learned you know
like light light light light is a weird
thing like it's so interesting it's so
interesting how you can create emotion
with light like with a little you could
take a
like a phone and like you light your
face in different ways and like it
changes the emotion oh yeah it's so
weird
I'm like holy [__]
like because like that's the
conversation I want to have okay people
give me advice how to light a scene all
that kind of stuff is great but the
reality is that a little bit of light in
a different direction that you have to
understand how that changes the Contour
on your face and everything and the
expression that your face can like the
the expression that could be effective
to communicate under on a different
lighting conditions and then like the
mystery of like having some of your face
uh in darkness and some not uh when you
can only see the eyes and not the face
when the background is visible or not I
mean there's the the yeah it's yeah it's
all just like this interesting art form
that's can be so powerful when you're
telling a story well and what's fun for
with me with photography and Rockets
they're both like the ultimate story of
compromise because when you start
learning about photography you learn
about you know how the aperture affects
both your exposure but also your depth
of field higher shutter speed affects
both your exposure your depth of field
how the you know of medium format camera
versus a crop camera effects you know
everything is a compromise and price
versus performance like there's always a
compromise you're always literally doing
like a trade study of what can I afford
What's My outcome like blah blah blah
blah how fast is the autofocus or
whatever
same with rockets like there's a million
choices and every single one of them
affects every single thing so there's
always all these trades and it's so cool
you can see uh the same totally
different outcomes based on the same
like requirements you know like do X and
here's how we're going to do it and you
know two teams of people come up with
wildly different things when did you
fall in love
With Rockets So yeah so the this the
story kind of keeps going for me so I
was doing it
can't talk photography man we'll get
we'll go on a deep Rabbit Hole there so
um so it ended uh you know I'm through
all this doing a lot of weddings I was
already getting saturated and feeling
like I'm not being as creative you know
you can only shoot them so many weddings
before you're like well now we do this
pose this pose this pose you know even
if like they're amazing places like you
know in front of a castle in Germany or
something I'm still like well at the end
of the day I'm
I'm not being very creative you know so
I remember craving like some some
projects and so I was sitting at my
friend's coffee shop
in my hometown in Cedar Falls sidecar
coffee and I'm sitting on this red couch
and I see this article from I think
Gizmodo and I said you could own
the flight stick of an Apollo Command
Module
and I knew enough to know what that
meant but that's really about the end of
my space knowledge and so I clicked on
it the click bait got me like I'm like
oh yeah I'm gonna see if you know and I
see that the minimum bid is like 250 000
I'm like okay no I can't own the Apollo
joystick you know but I got me on this
website called RR auction and so I
started scrolling through that looking
for things that hadn't been bid on and
they had that you know at the time
they're doing a huge space auction and
so I'm looking for things just out of
curiosity fun these are cool like
they're starting to really you know like
I said I liked space but I wasn't like
in love with it or anything but I'm very
just seeing all the stuff like this is
so cool look at all this old history
stuff
ended up seeing a um there's an article
for a VM SDK 44 flight suit high
altitude flight suit that came from the
Soviet Union
and looks you know it's like a MIG
fighter jet fighter pilot suit very
similar to like the SR-71 like kind of
pumpkin suit
um semi-pressure suit with a you know
full helmet I mean it full it looks like
a spacesuit you know for all intents and
purposes it's kind of like a spacesuit
and I just bid on it you know I've been
like I think 325 dollars and next thing
you know like it arrives at my door
yeah and from that point on like
literally I got it out I immediately try
to put it on and the first thing that I
do is almost die in it because I closed
the helmet down on myself and locked it
and didn't know how to unlock it so I'm
literally and so as soon as I seal it up
I'm realizing I can't breathe I'm going
to run out of air so luckily like
there's a hose you know that kind of
that long hose thing that would normally
plug into an Air Supply had a little
plug on the end of it so I just
unplugged it and was able to temporarily
breathe through the hose until I figured
out the locking mechanism
so there was my almost that was my
mortality rate thing right there so that
was probably above a 98 or below
panicking inside yeah for a few seconds
already reading like my premature
obituary like idiot dies alone in space
suit in his living room you know like
just imagine yeah that would be like
Darwin Award for sure for sure oh so um
so I get the spacesuit and it kind of
literally take my breath away
um
you should feel bad for that one you you
introduced Creed to me so you should
feel bad about that one star's wide open
yeah
okay so
um so I ended up like the space do kind
of like more or less haunted me because
it kind of just it sat in like my living
room for a long time and I didn't know
what to do with it and I actually had a
friend who is also a photographer wanted
to do like a photo he was just kind of
taking pictures randomly he's like hey
bring your spacesuit over we'll do a
picture it's like all right you know I
walk across the street literally lived
across the street Taylor and and I put
the spacesuit on I took this funny
picture of me like this is awesome and I
got a lot of like fun out of like
creating a character you know of
everyday astronaut or at the time I
guess I didn't know an astronaut and
then that kind of just continued I was
like thinking of more and more funny
situations where I could have this
astronaut on earth doing mundane
everyday things and came up with the
name everyday astronaut and originally
it was just literally a photo project
like this whole art series of an
astronaut doing these things these funny
Whimsical you know Silly mundane things
but I was researching a lot about like
you know I was trying to hide Easter
eggs like I was gonna hide in like the
you know the echocardiogram of of Alan
Shepard you know like his first flight
into space and photoshopping that into
pictures and like you know doing all
these little like facts about space
fight but they're just hidden little
elements in these photos and man doing
that I just fell in love with it I just
was going over every little detail that
I could learn I just couldn't stop
learning and I was I was getting excited
because I was like I could be teaching
people about all this exciting stuff and
all the cool things people figured out
you know 40 years ago 50 years ago and
was trying to portray that through
images on Instagram and you know it it
took me a little while but eventually I
realized you know on Instagram your
retention rate you're lucky if you get
like two seconds of someone looking at
an image you know or maybe nowadays 60
seconds of a quick little Instagram
short or something
but
um
yeah it doesn't give you a chance to
really teach to explore a little topic
that you felt like you felt the
Curiosity about the thing there's so
much to learn here this is so beautiful
there's so many opportunities to have a
light bulb go off for someone to be like
this is awesome
and so uh yeah I think I I started so at
the by the end of 2016 like throughout
2016 I realized I want to be done doing
photography as a profession and I want
to pursue everyday astronaut but I
didn't know what it meant yet I just
knew like I had this thing you know and
at that time I'd been doing it for
roughly two years and had you know seen
I don't know like 50 000 Instagram
followers or something I thought like I
could just be a full-time influencer now
you know like just go around taking
pictures of myself in a spacesuit and
doing public appearances and write a
children's book or something I don't
know I don't know what this thing is
I'll figure it out you know and so
um it basically I gave myself like a
Runway of one year of 2017 of like uh
I'm gonna throw stuff for the wall and
see what sticks
um so I was doing like twitch streams I
was playing Kerbal Space Program uh
which is like a video game like a
physics-based rocket building simulation
game but it's also like it's fun and
silly because you're not playing with
like humans you're playing with these
little Kerbal like little alien guys and
it's fun and silly
um you know streaming that on Twitch and
doing things and doing posting some of
those things onto YouTube but finally
like I said it actually happened to be
February 27 2017 when SpaceX had that
announcement that their flights went
around the Moon that I'm
I gotta tell people about this and stood
there and made my first like produced
YouTube video and I didn't want it to be
over three minutes
I was afraid that'd be way too long for
YouTube and I got it down to like I
don't know two minutes and 40 seconds or
something and that video uh wearing the
I was wearing the spacesuit yep and very
like horrible audio it looks like it was
color graded by a seven-year-old with a
tan marker or something like it just
looks terrible sounds horrible I'm
yelling no one's happy but
but the video you know did relatively
well like I had no followers on YouTube
like I had you know maybe 102 or
something is the video still up yeah
that's great okay this is so cringy and
as it should be you know your first
video should be terrible if it's not
terrible and you spent too long trying
to make it yeah so
um the the thing that clicked for me is
I had very little audience and all of a
sudden that video kind of took off you
know relatively I think it got like 10
000 or 12 000 views and I was like holy
crap that's way more engagement than I
don't have famous I'm famous now ten
thousand people that's almost my whole
town first of all that is kind of crazy
like 10 000 people is crazy it's crazy
like if you if you had 500 people attend
a thing that you do they'll be like like
you're like a rock star it's crazy we
lose perspective right yeah we really
lose perspective very quickly very
quickly so I made another video
um this one I spent more time on and I I
before photography actually I used to do
like wedding videography too so I had
done my woes with videography and
weddings and stuff I hated video like I
thought video was the worst took so long
to edit you know I loved RVs it's like
boom you Snappy post you're done in an
hour you know and videos like this whole
cumbersome thing so I thought I'll never
do video and here I was making this long
what it's the time seemed like a long
seven minute long YouTube video about
how the Falcon 9 lands
and again like that one I posted and
actually it did really bad and I was
really upset I'm like I spent two weeks
on this stupid video you know worked
really hard scripting and blah blah blah
and then it you know I had like a
thousand views or something it did much
worse in the first video and I was so
upset and I kind of like was ready to
keep throwing more spaghetti at the wall
to see what's gonna stick for everyday
astronaut and I think it was like a
month or two later I happened to like
you know check the analytics on YouTube
and also that video like kind of took
off and I got like 40 or 50 or 60 000
views or something I was like no way and
it just kept you know that just honed it
in more like Okay YouTube will bring a
bigger like bring an audience to me as
opposed to like Instagram I had to find
and you know try to get the audience to
come to me and this was like they were
gonna do the legwork so if I make decent
videos
um and I realized like really the fun
thing for me was explaining a topic that
was scary and intimidating and try to
make it you know fun and engaging what
were some of the struggles of uh
building up a YouTube channel so for
people who don't know once again
you have a YouTube channel uh called
everyday astronaut and there's some
incredible videos on it so what was the
what was the some of the challenges and
the struggles in the early days
definitely like At first you're not
gonna find your own voice and I know
like even you know Jimmy talked to you
about that like how your first video is
gonna suck you don't you're not gonna be
yourself you're going to be nervous
you're going to be you're not gonna know
the tone the pace the the things that
are interesting and actually originally
I I had constraints I was really worried
about making a short video because I
thought there's no way One's Gonna watch
the three minute video and then a seven
minute video and pretty quickly I
realized like YouTube as a whole was
kind of changing but also there's always
that historic backbone of like 22
minutes of programming for a 30 minute
spot on TV like no one goes over 22 or
44 minutes you know if you have the full
hour special or whatever like that is
the absolute limit of what a human being
can watch you know basically is what I
thought yeah and slowly I just kept
playing and getting longer and and
actually more and more in depth into the
topics and instead of getting like
pushed back you know and being like this
is so boring I realized as long as it's
like as I was walking people through the
whole step you know giving them all the
contacts they need they're happy to get
as deep into the weeds as I can get them
and so that just kind of fed the the
snowball just kept rolling and I'm like
all right and you know before you know
it I'm making hour-long videos like an
hour long is is more or less a normal
length on my channel for a for a
produced video and they're really really
in depth but I love like that process of
trying to preemptively kind of guess
what the questions might be and and you
know part of that is like we do like
script read throughs with like our
supporters and do like cuts of videos
and people a decent amount of people see
it before it goes public and I would get
those questions out of the way you know
we get those people asking the questions
and then I I love nothing more than
trying to
you know get all those questions
answered by the end of the video